this week on brian ross investigates
call to doodle the women of ukraine on
the front lines
now i say i love ukraine my kids and my
husband in that order
putting their lives on the line to stop
the russian invasion they're about 15 to
17 of the ukrainian military is female
but on top of that the women have been
doing a lot of support and also paying a
price for their courage on the
battlefield more and more stories of
violence used against the local women
in particular of soldiers using rape as
a weapon of war at gunpoint he took me
to a neighboring house he was ordering
me take your clothes off or i'll shoot
you.
then he starts raping me
plus the new coved way
shanghai on lockdown masked mandates
back in philadelphia dozens of
washington's elite testing positive
now we know 72 people who attended that
dinner have tested positive dr william
shaftner here with the latest and what
you should do now and this week's
winners and losers in the media good
news and bad news at cnn
thanks to wework kerry's company which
makes sandals out of recycled tires
booming from the studios of the law and
crime trial network in new york city's
herald square
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined by
my colleague ronda schwartz as always
and rhonda we begin with the call to
duty being answered in ukraine by large
numbers of women taking up arms and
challenging russian soldiers in any way
and every way they can rhonda that's
right brian and in what is sure to be a
lesson to other military fighting forces
that exclude women from combat
we are seeing and hearing tales of
courage and bravery from ukrainian women
on the front lines of all ages and
backgrounds
ukrainian women now make up some 15
percent of the fighting force
i am proud that i am ukrainian and
before this invasion i would say i love
my kids my husband and after that
ukraine in that order
now i say i love ukraine my kids and my
husband in that order
i'm not a woman i'm
i'm a person i'm a citizen of this
country
i'm a soldier a sergeant a combat medic
and i need to protect this country
this 79 year old ukrainian woman
attended military training to learn how
to use a rifle
others not on the front line are
confronting the russian soldiers
in one video a woman was shown offering
sunflower seeds to the russian troops
telling them to at least put these seeds
in your pockets so sunflowers will grow
when you all die here
in another video a woman yelled at a
russian soldier atop his tank
we're joined now by mia bloom a
professor at georgia state university
and international security fellow at new
america and professor bloom women are
very much on the front lines in ukraine
they are in fact my co-author on the
book on q and on past thousand
pedophiles sophia moscalenko she's
ukrainian and we have been writing about
the women in the ukrainian resistance
and in the military and we've seen
ukrainian women step up in ways that
i don't think we've seen since uh the
israelis were fighting in 1948 and women
fought side by side
clearly it's a dire situation there but
women are already in the ukrainian
military and permitted to be in combat
roles yes so there are about 15 to 17
percent of the ukrainian military is
female but on top of that the women have
been doing a lot of support so you have
grandmothers that are sewing flak
jackets and you have you know uh women
that are
working in in various support mechanisms
in addition to being on the front lines
a number of those women for example that
the russians captured uh they actually
shaved their heads so again this idea
some women are being uh abused very
heavily like in busha and then other
times the russians are just uh
mistreating female prisoners
but it seems to show that there's no
role in combat that women cannot perform
well i mean i can tell you as as someone
who had the basic training myself
very often the women are the trainers
because the you know you have these
machismo guys saying well if a woman can
jump out of the plane first i'm not
gonna not jump out of a plane so we've
seen that we've seen that women are you
know incredibly capable
and they're you know excellent at
multitasking which on the front lines
sometimes you need to be doing two
things at once
what's the message then for the american
military in terms of the role of women
in combat
i mean i think that that's been a long
conversation i can go back 30 years to
charlie moscow's at uh at northwestern
university that looked at what role
women should play and you know part of
the problem has been at least as far as
women in the military the officer corps
has always been white and the enlisted
and ncos have been non-white and so as
the officer corps was pushing for women
to participate
on the front lines so that they could
advance and get their medals the people
who would have been sacrificed would
have not been those white generals so
there has been a debate as to which
women in the military want to be on the
front lines but we've had women flying
sorties helicopter pilots in the united
states we've had women ambulance drivers
so we have women at all levels women are
really good though at things like
cyber warfare and they're excellent in
sort of many of these support roles
where they're not necessarily going to
be in in the most harm's way
we've also seen no hesitation on the
part of the russian soldiers in
punishing and abusing women they run
across women in ukraine are living under
a constant threat and there's growing
evidence of sexual violence more and
more stories of violence used against
the local women
in particular of soldiers using rape as
a weapon of war but only
my husband and i were there at gunpoint
he took me to a neighboring house he was
ordering me take your clothes off or
i'll shoot you
and this is something that uh dr
moscalenko and i are writing now we are
again as you can imagine for your
viewers this is horrific
this is where
we've captured we've found
communications in russian
that um women are telling their husbands
to rape the other women and you know
just make sure you wear a condom
um
so we've heard from busha like we saw
originally five
naked dead women on the road 20
kilometers outside of kiev but we've
also heard from bush another 15 women
who have been raped i think the numbers
are higher
but we also are now following a lead
that the russians are raping children
and 120 000 ukrainian children have gone
missing and the media isn't covering
this and so we want to make sure that we
let your viewers know that we're very
interested in preventing child
trafficking and and i'm very suspicious
of what the russians are doing with
those hundred and twenty thousand
children
will the women in the end make a
difference in the combat roles or
doesn't really matter the gender
i think it does i think well first of
all if you think about it this way with
the population when you tap 50
of the population that you weren't using
before you have a stronger military
but because the women are very capable
and they're very brave they can even set
the tone and so maybe someone is
wavering in in their approach having
that woman there fighting side by side
that man is going to feel you know
like more encouraged to fight and i
think also it's sending a very important
message to the russians this idea that
you can you know brutalize the women
during war time without there being a
consequence or cost that's not gonna
happen um these women are not gonna
stand for it they will fight back they
will shoot down the russian pilots and
they will you know blow them out of the
sky but the women are fighting side by
side and the ukrainian women are just an
inspiration
can they be as vicious as they might
need to be in war
i have never believed that women are the
softer sex and we've seen it in other
places especially when i study women in
terrorism sometimes the women were the
ones who were more radicalized than the
man so i think that we're not
necessarily going to see women being
weaker
and in fact there might even be
incentives for them to be even you know
more brave and and more harsh so i think
that women are capable of many things
including you know should it come to
this atrocities but uh what we're seeing
at least now
is russians committing atrocities
against the ukrainian women rather than
ukrainian women committing a trust
against soldiers
professor mayor bloom as always thank
you so much for being with us here
tonight
thank you so much for having me
up next another wave of colvin big
cities in china on total lockdown masked
back in philadelphia dr william shaffner
is here with the latest
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network